you'll make choices every day where you
say something like do I really want to
go to Bass Pro Shop if I do you know I'm
going to get a social credit score ding
I'll just go to the mall or something
you're going to want to buy a Bible if I
buy a Bible I'll just I'll just I'm not
going to buy one I'll just see if I can
get an old one somewhere else these are
the pressures they're going to put on
you so that they can control what you do
and what your kids do yeah yeah you guys
remember Kyle sarapan FBI whistleblower
who warned us that they were going after
Catholics now we're seeing this happen
on every level of the federal government
right now and it's disturbing but it's
keep happening and you know Christopher
Ray will downplay it the director of the
FBI will downplay and pretend like it's
not happening or it was just like a
little slip up oh one person did this
but it's not it's happening all over uh
the federal government right now and no
one's really stepping in to say much
besides you know this letter from Jim
Jordan thankfully but what will happen
we don't know well bass I wonder if bass
uh Pro Shop will even weigh in on this
or if they'll even go after them because
ultimately they're harassing their their
customers and that affects their line of
business wasn't that yeah I don't I
don't imagine they're going to shut
they're not going to say anything at all
they're going to shut their mouths